hello everybody we are back for another
vlog I'm enjoying doing these vlogs for
you guys I hope you guys like them too
if you do let me know below if you hate
them um let me know that too I guess
um but anyways I know I look more
glamorous and I normally do but that's
because I had the hair and makeup gods
work on me today for a TV segment and
yeah it always turns out way better than
I could ever pull off myself
but anyways on that note we're gonna be
talking about the holidays which are
coming up oh my gosh I need to start
Christmas shopping that's for sure I am
in no way ready for this but I think the
holidays can be both a joyous time and
also really stressful time for some
people depending on people's
relationship with their families with
money goals and also their relationship
with food and their bodies now I want to
acknowledge that I think all family
relationships are unique and complicated
in their own way but I think that even
in the most loving tight-knit families
commentary around food and body can be
so common and it often does not feel
very supportive and I think that this
time of year the holidays can be
particularly triggering for a lot of
people for a few reasons
so one I think that a lot of the
struggles that a lot of us face when it
comes to body image stemmed from our
childhood or when we were young and and
some of the messages that we were given
when we were young so seeing certain
family members can often kind of hash up
some of those memories too the holidays
are a time when there's just a lot of
food around so food becomes the topic of
a lot of small talk when we're kind of
tired of talking about the weather and
three you know a lot of us don't
actually see our family members all that
often so any changes to our body shape
or size can often seem more dramatic if
a family member is remembering us at a
completely different life stage now I
guess I'm kind of lucky that in my
family where I was growing up nobody
really ever talked about diets weight
loss or come
what people were eating that was just
not something that was really discussed
at dinner time um but I've since been at
the dinner table with a lot of other
unnamed people where this kind of talk
is completely the norm and I since
learned that as a woman living and
breathing in diet culture getting
unsolicited advice about your diet or
your body is pretty freakin common and I
get like a double dose of scrutiny as a
registered dietician about anything that
I eat or anything to do with my body and
I literally cannot go to a dinner party
without somebody coming up to me and
telling me about their diet or comparing
what's on their plate what's on my plate
so that's fine we probably all actually
observed food and body shaming at
different times in our lives and you
know depending on different social
situations you've probably played the
role of both the victim and the
perpetrator
so like for example maybe you're at your
holiday feast your family your family
event and you're kind of feeling full
and your grandmother's offering you pie
and you reject and she screams at you
what's wrong with you you're so skinny
you know are you gonna dye it or maybe
you're out like a buffet and you're
having a little slice of cheese and
you're putting those little little
pastries on your on your plate and your
mom comes up to you and she motions at
your hips and gives you the look and
she's like oh you you're really sure you
need that extra slice of cheese or like
maybe you're up for like a festive meal
with your girlfriends and you're just
like craving a nice crunchy fresh salad
and all your girlfriends start to tease
you and and and call you a diet debbie
downer and basically pressure you into
ordering the burger and fries like them
even when a commentary is not directed
at you it can still be hurtful and
impactful I know like a lot of families
watch holiday shows and holiday movies
together and it seems like a freaking
Christmas miracle if somebody doesn't
comment on some kind of celebrity and
the fact that
oh she's gotten grossly skinny or she's
she's gave a few pounds since her last
appearance there are probably so many
examples of this especially at the
holidays so if you guys have some
examples or experiences that
want to share I'd love to hear about
them in the comments below but what is
interesting to me is that even though
other people's food choices and bodies
don't really have like a whole lot of
impact on us we still feel the need to
comment on them when those choices don't
coincide with our own and that gets
really confusing when our choices are
not always the same and stagnant you
know throughout the year or every single
time we see someone I mean I cannot tell
you how many times I have been at a
family dinner and I basically begged to
have dessert and then the very next day
the exact same person will like look at
me disgust if I choose myself to order
dessert on my own so why do we feel that
we need to engage in this level of
judgment especially around the holidays
well I think there's definitely a few
reasons one there's the jealousy factor
sometimes I think people are just
jealous and and kind of longing for a
more balanced relationship with food you
know they see someone at the dinner
table who's I to have a modest Lysa pie
and a big salad at dinner time and not
need to go into that all-or-nothing
cheat game mode and then start
restricting again tomorrow
I mean body Envy is a whole other topic
and I'm sure that also can play into it
as well but I've seen a lot of body
shaming happening too and by a whole lot
of people with different body shapes and
sizes more importantly I think a lot of
people are trying to kind of justify
their own unhealthy relationship with
food so it's kind of like the idea that
hey if I'm on a restrictive diet and I'm
miserable then you should also be on a
restrictive diet and miserable or if I'm
having a cheat day and gonna eat all the
things and you should also have your
cheat day and eat all the things so it's
kind of like that projecting that we
were talking about in my haze versus
weight loss video in that a person who's
restricting may project their militant
view on food to everyone else around
them the other possibility and this one
is often quoted to justify the hurtful
commentary when a food chamber is called
out is that the family member is just
genuinely concerned about your health
and I think that's probably really true
often I don't think
family members make comments like this
to be mean or malicious or hurtful but I
also know that a research suggests that
people who are fat shamed tend to engage
less not more in health promoting
behaviors and be the holiday table is
just not the place
there are kinder ways to help support
somebody's health journey embarrassing
them at the family dinner table is not
one of them so that being said I thought
it'd be really important to arm you with
some shock responses and strategies that
some my dietician colleagues and I have
come up with and I think they're really
fun so if someone were to say to me Oh
Abbi I could never have both wine and
dessert I would reply oh I've just
enjoying my holidays and I'm glad you
found something that works for you but I
have found that listening to my body and
finding pleasure in food has been really
successful for me both for my physical
and emotional health if someone says to
me oh my gosh
Abbi why aren't you having pie you're so
skinny I would kill to have some pie I
would say back oh you know it looks so
delicious but honestly I've worked
really hard at trying to tune into my
body's needs and I think I would enjoy
this so much more when I've got a little
bit more room in my belly tomorrow so
can I take all the slice something like
that now if somebody makes a comment
about my body changing either getting
bigger or smaller or whatever I probably
say something like oh I didn't realize
you were looking at my body so closely
hmm I think that will shut them up
really fast or if you're feeling like
really sassy because hey sometimes what
happens and some people just need to be
told off you can also say something like
wow I mean please do not project your
insecurities on me I am really
comfortable with my body and food and I
really hope that you two can find that
sense of peace now regardless of which
end of the conversation you end up on
it's important to remember that our
bodies and food are really
really personal so for the days that
you're a victim of food shaming or body
shaming remember that the choices that
you make around food are yours and yours
alone and it's never your responsibility
to make someone happy based on what you
choose to eat or not eat if somebody
cannot find happiness in their own food
choices it's a pretty good indicator and
good set of evidence that they need to
work on their own relationship with food
and maybe the kind thing to do would be
to reach out if you feel up to it and
offer some support to help them get
there meanwhile for the days that you
are the perpetrator and listen I get
that dye culture is so pervasive that
we're all guilty of this sometimes but I
promise you that the flavor of your food
will not change based on what other
people are eating or weighing your kale
will not taste better if everyone else
is eating it and your cake will not
taste stale if you're consuming it alone
so if we all work at this together I
believe we can all settle into happier
healthier places with our bodies
ourselves and food and actually enjoy
the holiday season so on that note I
wish you a big big big happy holidays
from my kitchen here in Abby's kitchen
to yours if you like this video please
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below if you have any experiences around
food and body shaming at the holidays
and what are some of your responses to
family members who make not so welcome
remarks don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Pappy's kitchen bye
[Music]